thomas p.m. barnett what's the
pentagon's new map well what the book
tries to do really is nothing less than
to enunciate a successor to the cold war
strategy of containment in effect to
define the true sources of mass violence
and terrorism within the global
community so as to facilitate the at
first their containment through
diplomatic and military means but
ultimately their eradication through
economic and social integration and the
mantra I use in the book is that it's
disconnectedness that defines danger if
you think about globalization is a
process of integration then the
definitions of crisis we now face like a
911 are instances where connectivity is
disrupted and when you think about it in
those terms and you start casting what
it means to wage a global war on
terrorism within this larger process of
globalization spread you begin to see
how a bush administration can say in
effect to take down a Saddam is to be
part of logically is located within a
larger globalization or excuse me a
global war on terrorism because in
effect what we're dealing with is those
instances where you're going to find
very disconnected societies and it's in
that disconnectedness that we tend to
find the violence and the bad treatment
and in many ways what you're waging war
against with a bin Laden is a guy who
looks to take a big chunk of humanity
off line from the globalization process
and install authoritarian regimes based
on his particular definition of what a
good life is led before we get into some
of your thurs I want to go through
what's written about you in the back and
just quickly get you as where do we use
in Washington lot parse what is said
about you because we can get an idea
where you're coming from senior
strategic researcher and professor at
the US Naval War College from october
two thousand 12 jun 2013 19 what did you
do there well actually that goes all the
way back
1998 I had done eight years here in
Washington at the Center for naval
analyses which is sort of the ran for
the Department of Navy a think tank I go
to the Naval War College in 1998 and
become a senior strategic researcher one
of the key things I did during that time
period was I ran a series of workshops
with cantor fitzgerald atop the World
Trade Center where we brought together
Wall Street heavyweights National
Security Council members and OSD office
secretary defence planners and whatnot
and subject matter experts and we
explored the future of globalization and
what could threaten globalization and
what would be new definitions of
international instability and crisis
that gets wiped off the board with 911
because Cantor loses so many people at
that point the person who had been the
president of the Naval War College Vice
Admiral art zabrowski retires as
president goes to work for Don Rumsfeld
as his transformation guru they start
this new office within the office of the
secretary defense called the office of
force transformation it's going to be
about really transforming the US
military for the tasks that lie ahead
this administration comes in very
committed to this concept we're going to
build the military of tomorrow today so
art zabrowski calls me soon after nine
eleven knowing that my projects been
shot out from under me somewhat
literally and says come work for me we
need rationales we need an explanation
of the world that says not only that
we're transforming because we're rich
and technologically capable country and
thus can have a you know well endowed
and technologically enabled military but
that we're doing this transformation of
the US military in response to real
changes in the international security
environment that we think we now
understand in part thanks to 911 that a
certain world has been revealed to us
that's when I start putting together
this briefing which I deliver throughout
OSD I do it 150 times roughly to four or
five thousand DOD officials that tries
to explain a new way of looking at the
world a new way of understanding the
spread of globalization the connectivity
between national security and economics
and says this is where the global war on
terrorism fits within this is
the larger reference and that receives
good purchase within this administration
they let me brief it all over becomes an
Esquire article that becomes a book
that's why I'm here but I want to get I
want to get beyond that I want to get
beyond the language OSD stands for
office of the secretary of defense DOD
stands for department of defense if
someone were to walk inside the US Naval
War College first of all where is it
it's in newport rhode island how many
people would be inside it you're going
to see a staff of two or three hundred
they're going to process officers
graduate degrees about five six hundred
a year from all over the US military
primarily from the US Navy and Marines
but they also process hundreds or
several dozen each year foreign military
and what do they get one there they get
a masters in national security studies
and then you mentioned the center for
naval analysis where is that that's an
Alexandria Virginia that's where I
started when I got out of Harvard with a
PhD back in nineteen ninety at the end
of the Cold War how many people are in
that organization that is a federally
funded research development center it's
like the RAND Corporation basically
works for the Department navia load has
other clients as well that's about 400
analysts it's pretty sizable and most
people in there have what PhD a lot of
them do a lot of them do what they call
operations research kind of their
scientists I was sort of odd duck there
and that I was a soft scientist I was
political scientist what's the the
center from the institute for public
research is that that's the division
within the cna corporation easier by the
way a center for army analysis or a
center for marine analysis or a center
for air force announced yeah there are
those kites of those kinds of federally
funded research and development centers
and there are private corporations that
do that kind of work as well there's
also an Army War College in Carlisle
there's an Air Force War College air
college down in Alabama I believe those
are different from for example West
Point which does the undergraduate
degree for the army the Naval Academy in
Annapolis those kinds of situations at
one point in your your book you say you
wanted to be a Paul nitsa right what
does that mean well I mean
what was frustrating for me going
through and getting a PhD in political
science in the 1980s was that all the
rules with regard to how the Cold War
worked had been kind of figured out by
the time I got on the scene and started
studying them in a serious fashion in
the 1980s it was all fairly you know
carved in stone it was called strategic
arms limitation talks and we we knew
what was our part of the world in the
Soviets knew what was their part of the
world and we had all sorts of unwritten
rules that said this is how we interact
with one another and so it was fairly it
was fairly solid it didn't change too
much you could master the the field by
memorizing you know a pretty small list
of players and historical events and it
just wasn't a very dynamic arena as I
looked at it I thought I was just going
to come in and have a career in Soviet
studies got a masters at Harvard in that
first and then got a PhD in political
science I thought I'd be doing arms
control treaties for the course of my
entire career to all gone you live where
now I live in with my family in
Portsmouth Rhode Island actually on the
island where the Naval War College is
located it's a the original Rhode Island
and narragansett bay up in Rhode Island
and other than writing this book what do
you do for a living well what I do for a
living is I'm a senior strategic
research at the War College I conduct
workshops I conduct research I write
reports we have various clients that we
work for help them do strategic planning
within the US government were sort of
like an in-house consultancy at the War
College what is strategic planning lurgi
what other kind of planning is there
well strategic planning which the
military engages in in a way that's
different from I would argue the private
sectors that it's they engage in truly
long-term thinking I mean the military
DoD is one of the rarest places where
you can have a career where they
routinely ask you questions like help us
understand this particular dynamic in
the year twenty twenty-five okay you go
to McDonald's Corporation you go to a GM
they may go out five or ten years but
there are very few places that really
think down the
the pathways of potential global futures
to the degree that the Defense
Department does and that's fascinating
it's challenging but when you think
about it what the Pentagon really does
primarily as opposed to the commands
around the world that we have what the
Pentagon does is it spends most of its
time imagining future war creating a
force to wage that future war and
processing intelligence that supports
that definition of future war so to tie
it to something current today the debate
about the 911 intelligence failure I'll
tell you and I write it in the book in
my mind there was no failure okay I knew
exactly upon 911 that there would be
smoking memoranda found within weeks and
that there would be somebody within the
intelligence community who had been
screaming their head off in the days and
weeks and months up to that point why
that doesn't penetrate up the ranks in a
Pentagon is that the Pentagon decided in
the mid-1990s when they got far enough
away from the old Soviet threat and
started looking around for something
familiar to plan their future war
against because it takes a long time to
build all these ships in these aircraft
tremendous lead times and development
they got fixated on a China 1996 Taiwan
Straits crisis and so that became and it
still is in much of the Pentagon the
preferred vision of future war china
taiwan straits 2025 we run a lot of
so-called secret war games where the
unclassified description is a large
unnamed asian land power with an
unhealthy interest in a small island
nation off its coast okay and it's a
secret who that is except everybody
knows it's China so if you look at the
planning guidance inside a DOD right now
with regard to the technologies we
pursue the four structures meaning the
mix of ships and aircraft and whatnot
that we Bly you will see China looming
throughout these documents as the
dominant planning assumption so when the
Pentagon is focused on that definition
of future war and is building for that
and only wants to hear intelligence that
supports that people can be screaming
their heads off throughout the
intelligence community about an al-qaeda
in the days weeks months leading up to
911 that does not penetrate up the ranks
I mean the Pentagon simply wasn't
interested in that until nine eleven
made them interested let me ask you
about the most political statement you
make in your book okay at one point your
wife is afraid you're becoming a
republican right what does that mean are
you not a Republican well I'm a
registered Democrat I tend to vote
Democrat it's an odd thing to be a
Democrat who works with the military
which is overwhelmingly Republican I'm
comfortable in that in that milieu
because I like to be the skeptic in the
room I like to be the contrarian and if
you're going to be a contrarian in the
military environment you're probably
going to have to be a Democrat but
that's that's the family background I
come out of I had a grandfather who ran
as a progressive in was grant in
Wisconsin for the Senate and so that's
the kind of background I come from I
will tell you though I tend to describe
myself more like a Tony Blair Democrat I
tend to get lumped in because of the
work I've done with this administration
and I'm not a play called pointy I'm
just a government worker who was
elevated for 20 months to a certain
position in the office secretary defence
and therefore became known for that and
that was when you were the assistant for
strategic futures in the office of force
transformation in the office of force
transformation is there any easier way
of saying force transformation no I mean
that's one of those Pentagon buzz terms
what it means is this is the office that
imagines the changing nature of war and
is trying to get the rest of the
Pentagon to move in the direction of
accepting the challenges of the
information age and in effect moving us
off the kind of the industrial area
models that we've had for decades who
did you answer to who are you assist
arts lebowski and what was his title he
is the director of the office of force
transformation in the office of the
secretary of defense and who is he
answered to Don Rumsfeld secretary
defence what I'm trying to do is to
simplify this to where people get who
don't have any idea about any of this
and language and all that were they they
can get to the point should they go by
your book and what would you say to
someone who is drowning right now in
language about why they should buy this
book well I think what you're going to
find when you read the book is it is
written it avoids the jargon
by and large and it is written in a very
conversational tone it sounds like
listening to me talk about things across
the table as opposed to kind of a
high-concept here's a great race
throughout history and hear all sorts of
high concepts I'm going to throw at you
an in reckless abandon it is inner wit
it is interwoven with a history of my
career as a strategic planner which in
effect takes you inside rooms that you
don't normally go inside tells you what
it is to put together a PowerPoint
briefing to deliver a PowerPoint
briefing in some of these insider arena
to talk to people who are doing the
strategic planning and helping them
imagine the future of war in these kinds
of situations that I don't think the
public really understands and yet it
really determines the kind of force we
have so that when we're in an Iraq now
and we are short of certain things and
we don't have these certain things those
are all based on decisions we made on
what we bought over the last 10 years
and those were based on strategic
planning what's at PowerPoint briefing
well it's a hard thing to explain but I
mean most people understand what a
PowerPoint briefing is because it's
infiltrated large aspects of academia
and education and and they're fairly
common in the business world but inside
the defense community the PowerPoint
briefing is the dominant mode of idea
transmission much more than a policy
memorandum much more than an article or
a book you can write what it looked like
it's it's a series of slides that are
projected behind you and you stand up
and deliver a narration to these slides
now the classic way you see it movies
and why not they show you overhead
satellite pictures it's fairly static
pictures and they describe you know here
we're looking at here we're looking at
here we're looking at the kind of stuff
I do because it's very conceptual and
what I'm trying to do is explain a way
of thinking about the future of the
world my presentations tend to be highly
animated you say you actually say the
book you're pretty good at this well i
will i will tell you people have been
telling me throughout my career that I'm
one of the best PowerPoint briefers and
it's in it I will say that with some
humility in the sense that it's an it's
a very odd skill and it doesn't
people don't understand how powerful can
be inside the pen gun because it doesn't
have that same sort of power outside the
Pentagon the closest thing you see to
that kind of activity is probably your
weather man standing in front of a
screen and all sorts of animations and
maps and stuff like that changing behind
them as he describes something well I'd
basically do something like that except
the tableau that's behind me is the
future of warfare and I'm describing
where the world is going in terms of how
regions are coming together are moving
apart and I'm trying to sell a vision
for where DoD the Defense Department
fits in a u.s. foreign policy strategy
long-term that says this is the world we
seek to create this is the happy ending
we're trying to bring about let me then
jump to another easily understood point
you say we should take out Kim jong-il
well one of the arguments I make is that
if you're going to be serious about a
global war on terrorism what you're
going to end up having to do is
integrate these regions that are
historically poorly connected to the
outside world meaning the regions that
are poorly connected to the global
economy as we understand it people talk
about globalization and they make it
sound like it wasn't there 20 years ago
it's everywhere now to find that it
isn't defined globalization
globalization is is is is a connectivity
of communication networks it's a
connectivity of people travel idea
movement it's the connectivity of
economic trade in the movement of money
it's goods and services and ideas and
traffic and all sorts of connectivity
that develop in a mature fashion among
the most mature economies okay in the
aftermath the Second World War that core
that grows out this new core of a global
economy was based on North America
Western Europe and Japan if you listen
to the World Bank around nineteen eighty
big chunks of what used to be the Soviet
bloc sort of start coming online because
China starts to open up to the outside
world India begins to change over the
90s the Soviet Union breaks up we're
talking about some of the big economies
in Latin America you're talking about
the Tigers in Asia they start to
integrate with this global economy so I
talked about a
or a functioning core of the global
economy which is roughly two-thirds of
the world's population and then I
distinguish that from what I call the
non integrating parts of the world and
the reason why that's important to get
the gap what I call the non integrating
gap I mean before we go you're talking
about two different things that is where
he comes up all the time core and gap
core is two-thirds of the world right
and gap is the other third that is
poorly integrated to the global economy
name some of those I would run it from
left to right on a map it's the
Caribbean rim it's the Andes portion of
South America its most of Africa it's
the Balkans it's the caucuses its
central asia Southwest Asia and much of
Southeast Asia how I developed that
swath of the world and call it the non
integrating gap what we did was we
simply took and placed on a map the
almost 150 military interventions we've
engaged in since the end of the Cold War
so when did it go worryin for me 1990 so
I'm talking about the last 14 years
where have we gone because the Soviets
go away we get out of the bipolar
competition with them and you say what's
the natural demand pattern that the
world exhibits in terms of what i call
the exporting of us security what are
the situations that demand our attention
that attract our interventions 150 x 150
times and all i did was i drew a line
around that that figure and you have
that in the book right and i say what's
what unifies these regions and what i
find is these regions uniformly are less
connected to the global economy than
that functioning core and what's
interesting is that functioning core
there is no war in it there is no mass
violence but not always democracies oh
no not always democracies but when I
talk about in the functioning core is
that your what I see in these countries
are that they're they're consistently
seeking to synchronize what I call their
internal rule sets on economics markets
politics and whatnot with the emerging
global rule set that aside I got
stepping in because you use this a lot
rules set rule sets sets s ETS right
rules is it rule sets oral sets okay
rule sets real sets and you use that all
the time right what is a rule rule
well as I explained at the beginning of
the book one way to think about a rule
set is it's the way the game is played
it's the rules of the game okay so
American football has a real set
American baseball as a rule set hockey
has a real set the US economy has a rule
set the way the u.s. engages militarily
with the outside world has a rules and
you say it's changed in 1776 and in jump
ahead to 1861 or all the years it seems
like when war happened yeah because
usually what war represents is that the
rule sets have gotten so dangerously out
of whack the hat there is such either
anger or dissatisfaction in the system
that somebody tries to change the system
through war okay and the argument i make
about the 1990s is that globalization
had spread so dramatically to such a
larger portion of humanity that what
happened was was that the connectivity
raced ahead of the security rule sets
and the economic rule sets raced ahead
of the political rule sets here's an
example you get connectivity in the
internet and you have new definitions of
dangers like stalking on the internet
and until you create a law that says
stalking on the internet and create a
name for it there's a rule set gap there
there are people abusing new forms of
connectivity to do dangerous and bad
things and until you create a law that
says that's wrong I'm going to call that
wrong here's a new law there's a gap
between those two rule sets okay same
thing with the say identity theft you
get the connectivity of the modern age
and people can steal your identity until
we come up with this phrase identity
theft it wasn't even really illegal
that's where the economics and the
connectivity get ahead of the politics
and the security go back to Kim jong-il
okay take him out well here's that
argument about disconnectedness defines
danger so I look at the world and I say
show me the places that are poorly
connected I'll show you the violence
I'll show you all the wars all the
genocide all the ethnic cleansing all
the terrorists that we care about so
when I see a country that's disconnected
from the outside world inevitably bad
things are happening because who wants
to
connect a society from the outside world
somebody who wants to rule that society
in an authoritarian fashion and when you
give them that kind of power over people
they tend to do bad things to those
people and they tend to do bad things to
their neighbors they tend to become a
threat so I look at a Saddam Hussein I
look at a Kim jong-il Kim jong-il and
North Korea is one of the most
disconnected societies in the world
three million people we estimate we
can't even tell we think three million
people died of a famine in the late
1990s in North Korea why because Kim
jong-il refused to let the food
shipments come in to deal with this
famine he preferred to keep his control
over his people than to allow them to be
fed and on that basis he was I would
argue criminally negligent in the death
of three million people half a Holocaust
does anybody know about this it's a very
untold story it doesn't make the
newspapers why because North Korea is so
disconnected nobody knows what goes on
there it's like Stalin killing 20
million people in the 1930s we couldn't
figure that out until decades later so
when I see a Kim jong-il and I see that
kind of disconnectedness I say by
definition this is a bad guy and I will
argue if you want to make globalization
spread and if you want the rule sets
that come with that globalization to
encourage collective security and to
reduce the incidences of war you've got
to push connectivity for all it's worth
and removed from power those who try to
enforce involuntarily disconnectedness
on any society so Kim Jong Il's a
roadblock he makes Northeast Asia a
worse place than it would be with his
departure by the way back to your
PowerPoint briefings mmm how many times
have you given 1 i've given probably a
thousand or more how many people usually
in the audience anywhere from I do
sometimes I've done once for senior
leaders where it's the one guy in the
room and I've done them for as many as
five six hundred where there's another
two or three thousand that might be
watching on video communications you
know broadcast around the world and how
many other people are there in this town
like you that give PowerPoint briefings
well there are a lot of people give
PowerPoint briefings what I get told a
lot after PowerPoint
briefings is that they've never seen
anything quite like mine I mean my stuff
tends to be because it is high concept
because it does race through history and
because it presents a lot of big ideas
to get that across to people you have to
make it entertaining and you have to
make it dynamic so my presentations tend
to be highly theatrical it's almost like
watching a show in fact people have said
that I could probably take it and put it
on Broadway and charge money for it in
that kind of manner most guys like you
who give PowerPoint briefings don't end
up getting an Esquire magazine now they
don't end up writing books that are on
you know that this this book is kidding
see who published this GP putnam's sons
you know so it's a serious serious trade
publication I mean the Train mass a mass
book mass books yeah not a trade
publication in effect right well it's a
trade book they call in the hardback non
fiction category listen the question to
you though is how did you get this into
an Esquire magazine well I'll tell you I
spent most of my career across the 90s
making these arguments about how
national security had to come closer and
understand this process of globalization
and what I heard for the Pentagon was
it's a complicating factor you know we
don't do global economics we do war so
the only way I could get into people's
offices was to create this very
compelling entertaining PowerPoint
presentation and I knew that most of the
90s I was getting in because I was
awfully entertaining because people love
the PowerPoint they thought I was
fascinating they didn't know what any of
it meant in terms of how it connected to
national security but I knew that some
thing would come down the pike that
would make those connections more clear
911 did that for me okay at that point
my description of the world and saying
look where we go with our military
interventions we go to the most
disconnected parts of the world it's
where globalization hasn't taken root
all sudden the arguments about why we
wage war and why we seek peace in this
environment are intimately connected to
a globalization that becomes a package
and a message that has broader appeal
than just DoD and so I start briefing an
outside of DoD and on that basis I start
briefing it to private sector industries
like international financial community
to the information technology community
which understands this kind of stuff and
my tendency to employ
information technology metaphors in my
language it makes perfect sense to them
I mean this is a world they recognize
and so when I say this is where the
Pentagon and war and peace and the
arguments national security fit within
you know the great unfolding of this
globalization process that private
sector says I understand this is this is
good information for me as a business
person you get that kind of reputation
you start giving speeches to industry
groups s square comes along in the
summer of 2002 they say we're going to
do a best and brightest and they are
looking for strategist and they're
looking for a strategist who expresses a
new definition of how Warren peece
operate in this world because they say
after nine eleven things have changed
they ask around they're told hey you got
to see this guy he's got this brief it's
weird asal he gives it all the time he's
kind of a cult figure inside the
Pentagon people really like them they're
not sure exactly what to do with them
but he gets to brief everywhere so go
see this they send a guy up to Andrew
tchaikovsky one of their reporters up to
the War College he sits through two
hours of the brief I do it just for him
and he says this is unbelievable I've
never seen anything like this I didn't
realize people even thought this way
inside the Pentagon I mean I can't
believe they pay you to do this and so
they picked me as one of their best and
brightest they put me in the December
issue at that point Esquire says we got
to see this brief I come down I brief
the staff they give me some advice and
how to dress better as you would expect
from Esquire and they say that one image
that you got in here this map as soon as
that comes on the screen they say we've
got to get that map inside a square
because the world and our readership
doesn't understand this larger rationale
for the war on terrorism that this
administration is conducting they just
don't get it I mean the fear factor in
the American public is in effect where
are we going with us I mean we're going
to do Afghanistan we're going to do a
rack where are we going with this where
does it end what's the happy ending give
me a finish line describe how this ends
and what you get with the map is you get
a description of how the world works
where war fits within how that world
works and it gives you a sense of
progress you know judgments of measures
of effectiveness we are doing better
when we do this we are doing worse if we
do that it gives the american public
some way
to judge the actions of this
administration which I would argue
they've explained in a poor fashion in
terms of the grand strategy they just
say basically trust us on this we don't
think by the way of George Bush and what
he's done so far well let me get let me
get all the way to the book here on and
then I'll answer that question okay
because I have a tendency to jump around
and it makes a heart of hurt and so do i
so we're not careful so I write the
article for Esquire and it does you know
it's passed around the Pentagon it's
passed all over the world I get foreign
militaries secretaries of defense
calling me up saying wow this is you
know we were looking for this kind of
this vision of the future coming out of
DoD because this is one we recognize
this is one of Brazil or in Australia
can can understand and it makes sense to
us because the usual way the Pentagon
talks about war some gigantic war with
another great power 20 years from now we
can't even play in that venue but when
you talk about globalization and these
small conflicts that's something we can
marry up to so you realize it's not just
the American public that's looking for
this there are a lot of allies out there
who want this message at that point the
agents start coming after you and they
say you got to take this message to the
American public and I say now you know
I'm a weird guy mostly I do this
briefing I can't translate that to the
outside world and they say well you did
in the Esquire article so write a book
like the Esquire article and explain
your industry explain who you are and
what you do and the role you play so I I
cut a deal with mark Warren who's the
executive editor of Esquire and I say
you come and be my personal editor on
this book let's see who we can sell it
to we sell it to GP putnam's sons the
thrill their beam I got Neil nyren the
editor in chief who's tom clancy's
editor which you know has a certain
cachet in the national security
community and we say you know we're
gonna we're going to write this book
it's going to be part high-concept it's
going to be part an autobiography of the
vision and how this has come about
because I'm a nobody as far as the world
is concerned I have a certain statue
inside the National Security in
community but nobody knows who I am
outside so I have to explain Who I am
and how i came up with all these things
for it to be a sellable concept for
people say I not only believe it but I I
trust you as a source so we write this
book we spent a lot of time thinking
about how we're going to make it
translatable to a mass audience and what
we're getting so far in terms of the
response we're getting from readers
is it is understandable they can't
follow it they can't track it and it
gives them a sense of some comfort and
optimism it's fundamentally a very
optimistic book but in the end you
actually probably reach more people
through Esquire magazine you walk
through the book sale well it's hard to
say Esquire is big I mean I hope the
book will reach a large audience and GP
putnam's sons certainly hopes I mean
they're not in this business to produce
copies that only the elite read or even
worse one of those books that everybody
talks about but nobody actually reads
they want to push this as a book that
average citizens can read that'll give
them a sense of empowerment with regard
to how they can interpret you know all
these buzz phrases all this global war
on terrorism George Bush George Bush you
know what I basically say in the book is
I think the way to think of him
historically is much like a not at
Woodrow Wilson certainly not around
Reagan and certainly not some sort of
reaction to his dad the way I look at it
George Bush is I say he's very much like
a Harry Truman he's at a point much like
after the Second World War were
confronting what looks like a very
different international security
environment when we haven't seen before
and so he is in a very difficult spot of
having to put together in effect a new
national security vision strategy and a
foreign policy establishment that
supports that okay and to build
something that will outlive his
presidency to create strategic concepts
that other administration's Democrat and
Republican can pursue over time I try to
deliver that in this book I mean I sell
it quite openly as a successor to the
cold war strategy of containment like
they did back then define the bad areas
in the world the things that have to be
contained and try to shrink them over
time I'm doing the same thing here with
this Pentagon's new map do you find that
what he did in Iraq was right I make the
argument that if you want to deal with
terrorism I mean they're they're like
three ways you can deal with terrorism
roughly you can try to firewall off
America as much as possible to keep its
the computer against bad things coming
in from the outside I don't think you
can stop bad things coming in from the
outside okay so I think there are limits
to that you can try to kill terrorists
as quickly as possible but my argument
would be
they're going to grow them faster than
you can kill them I think what you have
to do is yet deny terrorists and
terrorist networks the outcomes they
seek and I would argue that the outcomes
they seek like a bin Laden is basically
to take a chunk of humanity and
disconnect it from the rest of the world
that they find so corrupt and polluted
in terms of its cultural influences so
i've bin Laden I would argue
historically it's not unlike a Lenin in
the Bolsheviks a century earlier in a
different era of globalization who said
I'm going to break off a chunk of
humanity away from the capitalist world
and to do that I have to find pre
capitalist societies like a Russia get
in there early hijack them from history
and take them down a different rule set
path where our rules are very different
from your rules and there's going to be
a lot of disconnect between our block
and your block and when I see that kind
of disconnectedness develop between
large chunks of humanity invariably they
start looking at each other as enemies
and there's danger and there's conflict
and there's insecurity so when I see a
bin Laden saying in effect I want to
grab the Middle East and pull it out of
the world because i think this
globalizing world is going to destroy
the Middle East that I know and love and
I refuse to see those cultural
influences change a Saudi Arabia or in
Iraq or something like that he's trying
to do the same thing that a Lenin did a
century earlier now how do you tie in a
rack situation into that the only way
you're going to deny the terrorists the
outcomes they seek in the Middle East is
to connect the Middle East to the world
and the only way you can connect of what
is today a very poorly connected middle
east of the world basically all they
trade is oil and all they take in is
money another than that they don't
really have much interaction with the
outside world compared to other regions
I mean in terms of percentage a trade
the foreign direct investment it
attracts the travel the communication
networks it is stunted in terms of
connectivity and getting more stunted
over time I would argue the only way
you're going to stop a bin Laden from
trying to pull off what he's going to
try to pull off in the Middle East is to
connect a Middle East faster than he can
seek to disconnect a Middle East from
the outside world now to do that you
have to take out those entities or those
agents within that security community
there which
is very insecure i would argue who stand
in the way of that and saddam hussein
was a tremendous force of
disconnectedness he created in security
throughout the region he kept the Iraqi
people tremendously disconnected from
the outside world so disconnected that
when we took down Saddam there was
almost a global mini boom in the
satellite telephone industry because
that was the only way you get a call out
of Iraq because there was almost you
know no cell phone industry there it was
that amazingly disconnected so when we
take down in Iraq and try to connect an
Iraqi society the outside world we
create and I would argue with the Bush
administration argues they seek to
create a big bang a transformative kind
of moment that says look this is the
connectivity that's possible we're going
to bring you into our world and by
bringing you into our world we're going
to deny the outcomes that a bin Laden
would seek which is a very isolated
authoritarian rule for the Middle East
that probably has very very little
interaction with the outside world and
as a long term pathway for that region I
see only danger and repression and
terrorism coming out of it just like we
saw between us and the Soviets show is a
good idea I think it's a good idea I
think it's a long-term idea and I think
the way it was sold the american public
was probably not so good and i think it
reflects the fact that in effect in the
global community we don't have a rule
set i can use that term we don't have a
rule set a to z you know from the
beginning to the end that says this is
how you process rehabilitate a
politically bankrupt state what's an
example of such a rule set i would say
we have 14 economically bankrupt states
it's called the International Monetary
Fund's sovereign debt chapter 11 ok you
can be Argentina and have a debt crisis
you will go into that IMF process point
a come out point Z you're rehabilitated
with no bias against you at that point
we do not have one for processing a bad
politically bankrupt leadership that
nobody wants that everybody wants to see
go on ok so the world wanted to see a
saddam hussein gone but we didn't have a
system for getting Iraq from A to Z what
we have is the UN Security Council that
does the
first few steps by saying we indict you
with this resolution we indict you with
that resolution then they turn it over
to who there is no executive function in
the international system that says okay
I will act on those indictments I will
take him down for you okay we sort of
have one called the US military but
there you only have a military that gets
you to the point of the removal of power
we don't have an international
organization or a rule set that says
this is how we build your nation back up
after we take down your leadership and
this is how we re integrate you into the
global community let me read a quote
from your book to see if you remember
this quote don't those idiots in the
White House realize they're destroying
the concept of deterrence for heaven's
sakes does this mean we're supposed to
attack China tomorrow because they have
nukes and might use them against us who
said that my mother said that my mother
said that after she saw the speech the
historic speech where George Bush
enunciated the concept of pre-emptive
war as a new cornerstone of US national
security strategy and what I say in
response to that argument is that you
have to understand there is one rule set
on security that exists within those
globalized parts of the world okay that
says in effect there is transparency
among states in terms of security issues
there is collective security there is
mutual assured destruction as a concept
to avoid nuclear war among great powers
that's a fairly stable rule set okay
there has been no war among great powers
since we invented nuclear weapons well
over us half a century ago okay none of
that changes with this new enunciation
of pre-emptive war because that
enunciation of this new concept of
pre-emptive war has nothing to do with
that functioning core of globalization
we're not talking about China we're not
talking about Russia we're not talking
about any of the great powers with
nuclear weapons going at it what we are
talking about are actors and rogue
regimes inside those non integrating
parts where the rule sets on security
have not yet extended where
globalization hasn't taken deep root
it's in those situations where we don't
believe we can deter people where the
rule sets on mutual assured destruction
and those kinds of things that keep us
secure in our nuclear arsenals and
strategic balances don't apply so
when Bush and this administration
effectively enunciate the concept of
pre-emptive war what I say is you got to
understand there are two different
security rule sets one that governs the
parts of the world that are integrating
and one that governs the part of the
world that is not integrating in effect
there's a lack of rule sets there and in
that more scary environment I think it
is reasonable to say if we find a Saddam
Hussein or Kim jong-il or an al-qaeda
and we don't believe they can be
deterring it makes sense to preemptively
wage war against him if we suspect
they're getting weapons of mass
destruction is your mother still in
Wisconsin yes she is where she lives in
boscobel where's that small town
southwest Wisconsin she has just
published the third volume of her
compendium which examines the history of
female protagonists in English and
American history literature she's up for
an Edgar later this week was an editor
and edgar is the award for Mystery
Writers what does she do she has she met
my dad in law school in the mid-1940s
after the Second World War my dad was in
the Navy she quit law school had nine
children at the end of nine children
worked in social services for about 20
years retired went back took her LS 80
went back to law school in her 60s
became a lawyer had a career in that
retired and then started writing this
great historical compendium examining
the role of female protagonists in
English and American history literature
which is almost kind of a lord of the
rings breath of work and she's up for
several awards is here from the mystery
writers the mystery fans of America yeah
I take it she's a Democrat she is very
much Democrat and what about your father
my father just passed away about a month
ago a month ago yeah how old was he he
was 81 he was a small town attorney for
about 45 years he was he was Atticus
Finch and he's another Democrat yeah he
was he was a Kennedy delegate a lot of
Republicans gone further back his dad
was a staunch Republican always playing
my mother for turning him into a
Democrat
we joke inside my family to seven
siblings as to which of us as we get
older is kind of turning Republican and
again I tend to vote Democrat a
registered Democrat I don't have any
problem working with Republicans at all
I mean my job as a government worker and
working in the national security
communities to make sure that America
has the best possible defense so I'm
interested in George Bush succeeding or
Bill Clinton before I'm and whoever
follows George Bush because I'm
interested in America being secure and
your wife's a Democrat my wife is an
ACLU card-carrying member she's very
much a Democrat so but did they get mad
at you for supplying this document here
that it reinforces what George Bush is
doing well there's a there's a certain
amount of concern in my family that what
I'm doing is helping reelect george bush
but you know i see that the challenge of
explaining where we are in history and
what we really need to accomplish in
this global war on terrorism and how we
need to link national security issues to
a larger understanding of how the world
works economically in this process of
globalization is historical unfolding I
see all those things is far more
important than whether George Bush gets
a second term anot so I see a lot of
good things in this administration in
terms of the responses they've made to
change the Defense Department and to
change national security strategy since
nine eleven I think they've done a poor
job of explaining that to people i think
they leave a lot of things unsaid and so
there is this fear of where are you
going exactly with this how do we know
you know what's progress where is the
happy ending and so i want to see those
holes filled I want to offer that vision
to America I think it's a tremendously
optimistic vision if it helps explain a
bush administration and makes it more
amenable on that level and helps them
get reelected I don't care one way or
the other you tell us on a number of
occasions in the book you're a Catholic
yes why is that important well I think
that explains the focus on rules the
Catholic Church very much rule-bound
sort of organization there are rules for
this and rules for that and so I grew up
in a Catholic grade school education
fundamentally interested in the rules
you know how things work what are the
rules of thumb what's the conventional
wisdom what are the unspoken rules what
are the written down
rules if you master the rules it's a
it's mastery in the system it's
mastering the the definitions of success
so throughout my career I've been very
good at getting grades or promotions and
those kinds of things throughout an
academic research sort of career because
throughout I've been very careful and
and made a lot of effort to kind of
figure out what the rules were
everywhere I went and to exploit those
possibilities as much as possible so
it's been my outlook on rules that says
when you get to this point in history
where things seem like they've changed
dramatically from a cold war where the
rules were kind of clear and Static for
decades a new situation DoD the Defense
Department after the Cold War looked at
the world called it chaos and I said no
that's not good enough we can't explain
the world as chaos because how am I
going to know where to go with my troops
how am I going to know where to wage war
you know pursue peace I mean I can't
make any decisions on chaos that just
sounds like a strategy of no strategy so
I've spent a career almost a decade and
a half trying to figure out how the
world works and how it makes sense to
argue that America plays an important
role in making that world work you're
how old I'm 41 daughter Emily get cancer
when she was two how old is she now 12
what impact did that have on well it
impacted me a lot in the sense that you
know to come to Washington and be a
political military analyst to be a
policy wonk of any sort fundamentally
it's hard to be somebody who's
optimistic and promotes positive visions
of the future because the washington
game is largely about tearing down other
people's ideas so the career I had up
until she got cancer 1994 was a fairly
caustic typical kind of i wrote negative
reviews of other people's concepts i was
specialist at decrying why your policy
your plan your proposal was desperately
dangerous and should be stopped i was
adept at that sort of research in that
sort of game when emily has her cancer
and and it reorders your sense of
priorities and what you want out of life
I decided at that point I was going to
stop being somebody who wrote about why
other people's ideas were
ad and was going to start writing about
a positive definition of a future and
why this positive vision was good and so
I stop quoting other people started
quoting myself I started stop tearing
down other people's ideas and started
building up my own and I got to a point
in the work about two or three years
after Emily's cancer where I thought I
can't do any more within the DoD
community to understand how the world
works in a larger sense I have to have
to gain access to other people and other
ideas and what the War College offered
up a new port was this unique research
partnership with cantor fitzgerald the
bond trader firm where they had asked
the War College to come together with
them and help think about the future of
the world and how globalization and
national security were coming together
that became the new rule sets project
that i had with cantor fitzgerald and
specifically with a retired four-star
Admiral as one of the senior people at
that point in cantor fitzgerald a guy
named bud flanagan and it was an amazing
exploration of how the world work and it
was in that process that i started to
get the sense of the rules and started
understanding there were more ways to
look at china for example than to say
this is a possible strategic competitor
of the United States down the road and
we should plan war against a China there
were other possibilities go back to the
Cantor Fitzgerald how many died in the
world trade center well from kennefa
sterile i think it was upwards somewhere
between 650 and 700 you know did you
know any of them knew quite a few of
them I mean we did a series of workshops
there all of them were at World Trade a
World Trade Center one on one hundred
seventh floor and windows on the world
restaurant so we did a lot of planning
at Cantor vestry oh we met with the
senior leaders there and did a lot of
planning of the workshops and
interpretations and analysis of the
workshop so I knew not only the people
who worked at can or who were the stars
but I knew the people who were the
security people and who cooked in the
kitchen and I mean all the ordinary
people that were there too and you know
it was how Dunning to have all that
tremendous loss of life I don't pretend
to have anywhere near the loss the
people who actually worked there because
these were acquaintances and these were
colleagues
and they meant a certain amount to me
but you know I don't they don't pretend
to have suffered as much as those people
that by any measure how how many days
had you been it before you'd been in the
World Trade Center when it on September
the 11th been there two or three dozen
times but I mean how soon before that
happened any minute well we met with
some senior Cantor people about four
days before the attacks and I was set to
meet I was going to be there probably on
a Tuesday morning probably about eight
thirty in the morning having breakfast
with the bud flanagan and Phil Ginsberg
two of the senior people at Cantor that
we worked with probably would have been
sitting right there 154 about two weeks
after 911 and it was just an accident
like it was for anybody who was there
but again the sep tember 11th situation
is there a need for a new rule set yeah
I mean Emily the cancer was sort of a
need for a new rule set in my family it
reordered my life my definition of what
was good and worthy in my life and I
think 911 was sort of the same sort of
shock to the system for the US political
system in the national security
community sort of said hey here's a new
way of thinking about crisis and
instability and threats in the world and
we got to have new rules for dealing
with this or we got him yet well I mean
you fly in a plane do you think we have
some new rules in terms of how you fly
in a plane yeah there's been quite a few
rules they're there been new rules
regarding the nature of how we treat
information in our society the nature of
privacy we have new rules for what's
considered criminal behavior terrorist
behavior on American behavior there's
been a lot of new rules I would argue
that it put upon the American public in
the system since nine eleven the Patriot
Act is a new rule set which scare some
people makes other people feel more
secure the pre-emptive war concept is a
new rule set so we've we've created a
ton of new rules since nine eleven and
you know all those new rules are
frightening to people I would argue
because they're different they change
behavior they ask new things from us and
until you provide a vision that says
this is why it makes sense this is why
it represents progress here's how i can
describe a better world in 10 or 15
years that will come from these
sacrifices it will come from having your
sons and daughters and husbands and
wives you know engage in these
activities across the world because it
is real sacrifice
and these are you know important people
that we lose each and every time in your
book talking about you've got a big book
here talking about the Pentagon map and
the future in rule sets but on page 365
you start talking about raging debates
and you talk about the profession of
television in the media absolutely and
you say I simply cannot watch most of
these shows for more than a minute or
two without sensing that my strategic IQ
is dropping with each idiotic soundbite
offered often hurriedly so let's the
buzzer on the countdown clock drown them
out most of these discussions focus on
generating more questions and answers
right because questions are what keeps
you tuning in but the cumulative result
of this flood of unanswered questions is
a public that often feels overwhelmed by
current international events when simply
put we need not be television doing a
disservice I think it is in many ways I
mean a venue like this where I can talk
about a book for 25 30 45 minutes for
getting a chance to do that on talk
radio I mean you get a chance to discuss
a complex book complex material a big
vision that describes how the world
works and where we need to go I say try
to sound buy this book in 35 seconds in
an explanation on one of these countdown
shows it's hard because what you get in
that kind of tight timeframe environment
is you get people shouting at each other
you know basic phrases and and the focus
is on the tactics of the day how are we
going to get out of Fallujah how are we
going to deal with the uprising in Basra
you know what how could we describe what
happened in the last 24 hours how can we
describe what we're going to do in the
next 24 hours and the public needs that
kind of reporting to a certain extent
but with 24 hour broadcast news networks
we also need to see a lot more
discussion of the long term strategy
okay inside the Pentagon when you brief
inside corporations when you breathe and
have you ever brief to Congress I have
briefed a Mac Thornberrys group and on
the hill today i briefed the house of
commons over in England do they sit
still long enough to hear it absolutely
absolutely would you say to the public
that if they saw what goes on inside the
Pentagon with these hundreds of people
devoted to analysis and strategic
finding that people are going through
these issues they are they are thinking
very strategically but you know what the
material that's developed there that
drives a lot of these decisions that
creates these situations where people
say how does this happen and you get
these tell-all memoirs that were flooded
with now what did they know and when do
they know it all backward looking all
focused on on details nobody look into
the forward I mean that's where this
kind of look I think plays a certain
unique role because it says let me take
you inside those rooms let me show you
how these long-range strategizing
sessions unfold let me show you the
content that's involved in how they
impact decisions that you think are
controlled by you know unnamed forces
for instance you go way out in the
future like 20-25 where you say we might
need an Asian NATO absolutely and that's
one of the reasons why i want to take
down a Kim jong-il because I see for
example right now a plan within the
Pentagon that's been recently publicized
in New York Times to create a missile
shield to deal with the threat coming
from North Korea it would protect a
Japan South Korea doesn't even want to
be involved it would protect a Singapore
and others good idea well they say it's
about a North Korea what anybody who
looks at that picture notices
automatically as China's on the other
side of that line too and they will say
what this is really about unless you
believe Kim jong-il has a very long
future is about creating some sort of
deterrence or shield from Chinese
missiles General Eisenhower warned us
about the military-industrial complex
and driving policy right we have a 450
and above billion dollar defense budget
right is it enough I think it's I think
it's more than enough i mean if all you
want to do is defend this country i
could defend the country for about a
hundred billion dollars if we're
spending 400 billion dollars we're doing
something besides defending this country
and my argument is what we're doing is
we're exporting security around the
planet and making the world a more
better and stable place did i do i think
it's a very good idea because i think
we're the only country that can actually
pull it off and that when we do that we
create peace and prosperity that
benefits us in a tremendous way should
jump should some of the others I didn't
mean nervous you some of the others pay
for this that's the question that's
going to make us the point
make they do already okay we float 100
130 140 billion dollars in Treasury
bonds first quarter 2003 four-fifths of
that money was bought by foreigners
guess who the two biggest buyers were
Japan and China ok that's a transaction
when I accuse this administration of
waging war within the context of war and
not explaining war within the context of
everything else and that's what gets you
a charge of unilateralism did we wage
war unilaterally interact well if you
don't count who paid for that war then I
guess we did but if you count who pays
for it then you understand that that's a
transaction and if you don't make China
and Japan happy with that transaction
they're going to stop buying that
service called US military military
interventions you ever have people like
Paul Wolfowitz or a jump to the
political side Karl Rove call you up and
say go Tom go we love what you're saying
well I don't I don't operate at that
level and I try not to operate on their
level on some level or most instances
because once you get up into that level
then you get caught up into the
political debates and it's hard to have
a vision that can be a political or as
esquire likes to call it maddeningly a
political that it's hard to tell unless
I reveal to you whether i'm a democrat
or republican because i make arguments
that seem to fit both camps I try to
stay out of that Paul Wolfowitz call a
roll row of kind of level because once
you get caught up in its you get
politicized and I prefer to be operating
in a level where I'm talking to the
captains and the Colonel's in the
military's the guys who are going to run
this military 10 years from now because
if I capture them I capture the future
on the cover of the book it says Thomas
p.m. Barnett before we close out what's
p.m. stand for my mother named me Thomas
a Patrick Barnett when I took my wife in
marriage she said if I'm taking your
last name you're taking my last name I
said I'll fit it between my middle name
and my last name so M stands for Moyes
Lane my wife's maiden name here's the
cover of the book it's called the
Pentagon's new map war in peace in the
21st century Thomas Burnett our guest
and we thank you very much thanks for
having me sir